you're gonna tell me what happened the
other night i haven't where
working with chris maloney what's that
been like great you know chris is a
great guy
and we've had fun together he's so well
suited for his character
and we've only had two teams together
but they've been uh
great scenes there he is right now but
he was about to walk in with handcuffs
and take you down yeah
it's gonna take me down
dylan is the bad guy chris maloney is
chasing in law and order organized
crime more than seven and a half million
people watched last week's premiere
but this show is a little different than
the other spin-offs
you're dealing with a dangerous man yeah
smart and dangerous
this is a high level highly intelligent
different criminal you know but the
great thing about this show is that we
get to go home
with the bad guy we don't get to see
that too much on television
why would i ask permission from someone
who doesn't even deserve
perception people love law and order i
mean it's just
one of the most successful shows in the
history of television
and now you know organized crime will be
on for 22 years
are you ready are you committing 22
years i'll be 80.
look elliot i don't want to push you
what do you think it would be like for
your character to go up against marishka
hargitay
hey whoa that'll do something
you